got a girl's number on the on the
highway like having her uh like turn
Hunter no no oh I I air dropped my
contacts to her what you guys are
driving side by side
[Music]
a Southwest Airlines flight was nearly
turned around
when something pretty interesting was
happening between passengers and I'm
gonna play this you were squabbing they
were asking are we there yet
what happened so I'm gonna play this
right now so here's the deal this
continues while we're on the ground I'm
gonna have to all back to the gates
everybody's gonna have to get off we're
gonna have to get security involved and
it's vacation is going to be ruined so
you folks whatever that airdrop thing is
let's send a naked picture let's get
yourself
when I was in Hawaii so I'm gonna air
drop me in an airplane what'd they send
you the it was uh from I got her I Got a
notification saying
um Kris Jenner would like to airdrop you
a photo
[ __ ] when I was coming from Hawaii too I
always decline man yeah I just declined
I auto decline dude even for my wife
let me see if I have it I've never got a
random Air Drive really this is what I
got
what does that say
it's a picture of Kris Jenner saying you
got Christ that's all it says wait so
they have to go back because someone
sent naked pictures on airdrop they were
sending a bunch of naked photos all over
airdrop back and forth so it's okay to
airdrop people's stuff as long as it's
not obscene
I don't know but be like hey I'm a
[ __ ] stock broker check out my phone
everyone had to get out of the plane and
then the [ __ ] cops are gonna crack
down on who did it they didn't have to
turn the plane around everyone chilled
out after that but this was a viral Tick
Tock because of what happened which
means it's gonna happen a lot more on
fights now exactly right because you can
go viral this way and that's so annoying
uh but I know I've seen like
yeah I've had it happen to me I didn't
accept it because I was just like I was
probably gonna be some dick
yeah and this was before they even they
even took off yet so you could make a
lot of money off that it's like oh man I
hope it's some dick oh my God this is a
picture of Kris Jenner oh no I wouldn't
accept it because you just don't know
what it is like it could be
incriminating [ __ ] it could just be
[ __ ] weird yeah exactly I don't
believe anything yeah I don't care what
the [ __ ] it is dude yeah it's not like a
bunch of old folks dude yeah that's a
high risk through a picture can they I
would accept dying online so this is
this is like that's my guy Chris you
think it's just like random naked stuff
or this is like the same thing as like
one of those [ __ ] streakers but like
instead they're just doing it digital oh
so it's their [ __ ] yeah they get off on
it that is what's happening yeah you're
right it is you can't trace back like
who did it no you can't you'd be like
that guy's body type
everyone whoop your dicks out it's like
that guy's going like this it's the one
who's all you know yeah laughing yeah
that's a dead giveaway yeah it doesn't
show you like on airdrop like who it was
saying I got that picture I stood up and
tried to look around did you I wanted to
make eye contact with someone like who
was it yeah yeah yeah I did hear like
half of the plane giggle after that
airdrop was sent that I didn't accept
and I was like oh that's probably like
everyone did accept it they're like oh
that was funny what if Nick flipped the
[ __ ] out who the [ __ ] did that shot he's
like I got crisp
[ __ ] is that I don't get Chris my name
is Nick Dunn I don't get [ __ ] Chris
who the [ __ ] sent that to you
thanks Nick Dunn oh you know what Tim
says he does that [ __ ] well you just
send [ __ ] up Ryan does too yeah Ryan
yeah
I do it I do it to [ __ ] up people's
recordings
I don't really I'm not trying to
actually yeah I better drop the comedy
show flower I've done that hey that's
cool that's smart my comedy show yeah
that's kind of desperate too that's I
like I know I did it I ran it you know
what I'm saying
it's the New Age of Ultron it's a
preview of what's in store it's like
it's not this isn't even in your final
destination but um if you happen to be
coming back yeah yeah it wasn't at an
airport I don't actually don't remember
where it was at but I remember I've done
that at the comedy show air dropping
I've actually got an airport okay I've
got a girl's number on the on the
Highway by like having her uh like turn
Hunter no no I I airdropped my contacts
to her what you guys are driving side by
side so so she was like uh yeah she was
a hot chick whatever and I caught her
attention and then we like you know then
we ended up like speeding up and got
next to each other again and I'm telling
her like air drop air drop turn your
airdrop on and she's always like okay
all right you know and so like
motorcycles she [ __ ] admits or
something [ __ ] goes 20 feet which is
literally all right
and so uh yeah I sent I sent my contact
and when I when I clicked like a iPhone
3 or whatever I clicked it and then I
was like did you did you get she's like
yeah I got it and then she texted me she
was like that was the smoothest way I've
ever gotten a number oh so what happened
after that yeah what happened after that
we texted a little bit and then and then
she was just like how many people have
you done that to and I was just like
what why you gotta ruin that [ __ ] yeah
how many girls how many girls have you
done so I was like yo this was actually
the cool I've never done that before
this was cool and then she just you've
never done that before yeah yeah all
right you go like how many guys have you
gave in your number two yeah guys
they're too smooth
like 16.
sabotaging her own [ __ ] yeah
fell for it
that's pretty cool you should just
responded with how many guys have you
said yes to yeah I guess that's true
true I was just like damn this was a
cool moment you're already like losing
trust you don't say LOL
you could have said how beat is that
[ __ ]
how big is that [ __ ] how beautiful you
think I sent it with confetti and that's
what the gynecologist would ask
does there happen to be a photo of this
uh air droppage no foot of the air
droppage no photo of the nudes as usual
you host the show you know the story
so it was direct yeah it was a direct
well I don't know what they what kind of
sandwich they had actually oh this is
normal stuff they don't it's not
sandwiches it's Southwest you have to
pay for sandwiches they give you nuts
only whoa actually actually peanuts
usually pretzels it's usually pretzels
thinking about like fire so during covid
right all the guys on Hollywood
Boulevard that asked if you like hip-hop
like they had no clientele because
because it was covid right so I think
the best thing that they should have
done is everywhere they went they should
air dropped a meme of themselves going
to do like hip hop
and not their album if they weren't
resistant to Modern ways of advertising
yeah and they still use CDs
I'm waiting for a billboard to free up
with a guy who just says do you like
hip-hop
you can't give away his album and
there's no way for you to answer he's
just looking at it like I do but I love
it actually what next is do you like
hip-hop and then on the next one he's
trying to put his music around your ear
oh that's good just trying to put the
headphones in your hand you get a sneak
peek as you drive up yeah that's not bad
that's kind of tight when to let have
you ever done something based on ability
yeah Larry H Parker dude
I've never done it but you know them
right it's like the [ __ ] Adriana's
Insurance
yeah sweet dreams is this lawyer who has
a dentist a four four four four four
four number that's it that's his uh he's
all the only number you gotta remember
is four this is his billboard four the
only one six seven seven seven seven
seven seven
days I would say that the only ones that
are kind of nice are the ones are like
lizard Show April 4. yeah convention
convention Boat Show yeah well my
favorites are like on the way to like
Vegas or something it's like McDonald's
exit two miles I love those Billboards
are they [ __ ] tight like Peggy Sue's
in 50 minutes or some [ __ ] you're like
damn that I'm hungry have you heard a
book yeah it's one of the biggest gas
stations and they got Shen Yoon in Texas
though
everywhere he's like what I've never
even heard it did you call me
sure you can I'm not attracted of karate
fighter guy popular series
no thank you well it's a quick Time game
though it's kind of lame quick time yeah
yeah so do you guys want any real
gameplay very slow talking do you guys
want to list more of your favorite
Billboards anybody else
um
so five they're promoting all the strip
clubs in City of Industry oh those are
nice oh yeah
in Vegas too they just have like giant
trucks to drive around like with those
little thin Billboards it's like escorts
escorts escorts and the numbers like six
nine six nine it's like a girl in a
bikini and it's like a golf course and
it says like in in like Nevada Northern
Nevada or whatever but there's like a
resort and apparently it's like a like a
Resort golf course and there's like
girls in bikinis there like that are
your caddies well apparently the win
actually with their golf course they
hosted a collaborative uh I think it was
with Crazy Horse or with crazy girls and
they actually had strippers be caddies
for the tournament oh wow and I think
that there was actually strippage I
don't know not at the wind can you tell
it again like put in the way that JoJo
said it where you're almost having to
tell it to your chick but like in a way
like that you don't like it
yeah like it doesn't appeal to you yeah
this side quest lead
do you know has anyone ever taken that
this one called the numbers are like way
older now where does that what happens
when you bite that yeah when you call
the number what happens where does that
go I think it's a call escort number
that's it that's all it is and I think
that number leads to a menu it's not to
a direct person I release the menu of
girls that like blah but I think also
all those girls are like way way younger
in their photos
because I remember back in the day when
that guy was there it would be like 40
Mexicans in neon t-shirts just doing
they're not there they're not there
anymore wait what is this I mean in
Vegas a couple of them are still handing
those out like on the Strip so Vegas at
the strip almost every intersection or
even almost any opening to any parking
garage like you walk down the strip
there's the Mexicans and like the neon
yellow or Neon pink shirts and they're
passing out like these flyers like
little like flyers I've seen little cars
they're exotic girls yeah numbers right
on the back with like a little ass star
on their nipples but you can still yeah
yeah you're like and they stand there
and they slap the papers together to get
your attention oh gotcha and then and
then when you get close they'll go like
this if you don't get it I'll just go
back to that you just hear it like and
around them it's like probably 750 of
those cards on the ground on the ground
I can't say no so I always take them
crazy yeah I always have a bunch when I
leave but it's like oh okay well like
you know this isn't working bro I've
always wondered like because you know
like in Westworld where like in West
will they go in there's a guy going come
get the treasure with me no thanks I'm
gonna go over here they remind me of
that like what happens when you take
this road yeah yeah it's usually like uh
let's just say as long as we if we all
know about them and they've been doing
them for years people are calling well
not anymore though I haven't seen them
you were just there's way fewer you were
just there right yeah these people still
on sidewalks from time to time it's a
little bit more discreet definitely back
in the day it was like every everywhere
yeah there would be like shoulder to
shoulder yeah even though the bridges
would be like two of them like
everywhere there'd be more of them than
pedestrians sometimes yeah maybe that
was their growth part of their business
and now they're done with that and they
saturated already and matured uh their
own users but it is weird though because
you'll see them and like a [ __ ] guy
with a Pikachu costume and it's got like
a stain on the like tail or whatever and
there's like a broken like Transformer
and then they'll be like those uh show
Girls Girls yeah oh just paste these on
so it's like the stripper version take a
picture take a picture Transformer it's
Bumblebee and he's going
foreign
[Music]